Game of Thrones Season 6 episode 7 is
out let's have a look we meet brother
ray a priest who leads a village
somewhere in the Riverlands it seems a
pretty nice place they've got going
they're working together to build a Sept
a seven sided structure that serves as a
Church of the faith of the seven brother
ray is similar to a book character
called the elder brother he leads a
group of monks who live on the quiet
Isle seeking atonement for their sins by
taking vows of silence Brienne visits
this island in the books and there she
sees a certain monk digging graves
he's unusually tall and he limps as
though his leg was hurt and he's subtly
associated with dogs so fans have
speculated for years that this grave
digger is the Hound remember at the end
of season 4 Sandor is beaten by Brienne
and left for dead by Arya but we never
actually see him die so the theory in
the books is that he's rescued by the
elder brother and now lives on the quiet
Isle and that's basically what happens
in the show Sandor saved by Rae and now
lives among his people in the books it
seems as though Sandor finds peace in
his new life that he lets go of his
hatred and violence he actually becomes
one of the monks atoning for his sins
though in the show Sandor says hate
keeps him going he chops wood like he's
trying to murder it he seems pretty much
unchanged from the violent dude he was
before so maybe we'll see more change in
his character later races the gods have
plans for Sandor Clegane in King's
Landing we see a very different sort of
priest the high Sparrow visits Margaery
who's still acting all faithful and
pious she's also got a funny little
crown look because Tyrells do love their
headwear but they quote some scripture
at each other and the sparrow makes a
comment that you don't have to know all
the texts to be a good pious person
which reflects on Rhea rush he plays it
pretty fast and loose with his theology
says he doesn't know much about the gods
but nonetheless he uses religious ideas
to help him build a happy community Game
of Thrones shows that there are lots of
different ways to be religious some good
some bad and most a bit of both but
anyway the sparrows hits marched down
gives her a creepy priestly touch on the
thigh and tells her that she should be
having more sex with Tommen it seems
like the sparrow wants to make sure that
Tommen and March have a child which of
course is very politically important
right a son of King Tommen would be the
heir to the Iron Throne
so maybe the sparrow is making sure that
his power
through Tommen we'll survive even if
Tommen doesn't the sparrow then subtly
threatens Alayna so much goes and visits
her with septa unella watching over
Mudge talks the talk acts like she's on
the sparrows side but she secretly
passes a paper to a laner with a drawing
of a rose this refers to the sigil of
house Tyrell so what marge is saying
here is that while she pretends to be
all pious she is truly still on the side
of Tyrell so one of her goals at this
point may be to free her brother Loras
somehow up north Jon Snow tries to
recruit the wildlings for his battle
against the Bolton's and the wildlings
are in a really terrible spot right now
stuck between the north moon who want to
kill them and the White Walkers who want
to kill them then turn them into zombies
Jon argues that the wildlings best hope
is to side with the Starks and retake
the north
tormund argues that they owe John
because he saved them by letting them
through the wall these are both strong
arguments so Jon gets an endorsement
from one one and the wildlings votes no
it is weird that just a few episodes ago
tormund said that the wildling think
that Jon Snow's a God because he rose
from the dead but for people who think
he's a god they still need a lot of
convincing to follow him no one seems to
think it's a big deal anymore that jon
was resurrected
Melisandre got all excited about it said
Jon might be the prince that was
promised but we've barely seen her since
jon himself seems pretty much unchanged
by his resurrection his personality
seems the same what's the point of
killing than resurrecting a character if
that character doesn't change from the
experience hopefully we'll get something
more before the season ends back in
King's Landing Cersei tries to allow
with Elena but the queen of thorns tears
her to shreds points Heather this whole
mess with the Sparrow has started
because Cersei allowed the faith to arm
themselves
Elena suggests that Cersei might be the
worst person she's ever met and Cersei
has done a lot of terrible things
framing the Tyrells framing Tyrion
having King Robert killed killing Lady
beating Royals killing Dwarfs and that's
just in the show she does even worse in
the books not to mention her terrible
political and economic decisions that
damage the whole realm and that she's
just generally cruel and horrible to the
people around her so some would call it
justice that now Circe's lost everything
her power her prestige her father her
firstborn her daughter in the books even
her brother and lover is slipping away
all Cersei has left now
is Tommen and he's in the hands of a
scheming zealot really the only card
says he still got up her sleeve is the
mountain so you can be damn sure that
she's going to use him Jaime and Bronn
arrive at Riverrun which is held by the
blackfish Brendon and Tully the castle
is under siege by the phrase but they
aren't doing a very good job so Jaime
has come to sort their [ __ ] out and take
the castle in the name of King Tommen in
the books Jaime has a lot of complicated
feelings about this siege for one thing
back in book in season 3 when card
releases him from captivity she makes
him swear on his honor and his family
and his gods to never again take up arms
against dark nor Tully
but unless Jaime can convince the
blackfish to give up Riverrun peacefully
he'll need to storm the castle and break
his oath this affects how Jamie sees
himself he's known as the Kingslayer
a man with [ __ ] for honor but now he's
trying to be a better man to keep his
oaths another complication is the
blackfish himself Brendan was a war hero
back in the day and as a kid Jaime
idolized him wanted to hear all the
stories of his exploits but now Jaime is
set against the man he once admired
Jaime's been forced into a war against a
hero he looked up to and against a
family he swore never to attack on top
of that he's still reeling from the loss
of his hand and the loss of his father
which he feels responsible for Kaz he
freed Tyrion who killed him and in the
books he has a falling out with Tyrion
and in the books Jaime starts to break
up with Cersei basically Jaime's life
has fallen apart and this siege is the
stage where he starts to rebuild himself
not as the douchey prince charming he
was before but as a better nobler man
that's what's up in the books anyway
John Sansa and davos arrive at Bear
Island home of house Mormont the moments
are a really cool family their leader
was jaw until he went off to join the
Nights Watch Joe left his son Jorah to
rule until he got caught selling slaves
and ran off to Essos where he ends up
serving Daenerys so jaws histo mage took
charge and she's this tough warrior
woman type who fought alongside Robb
Stark in his war mage has a bunch of
daughters warriors themselves and
interestingly it's not clear who the
father of her children is because a
husband is never mentioned but there is
a theory the wildling torment seems to
have a bit of a thing for warrior women
right and he does claim to have [ __ ] a
Schieber mages nickname
is the she-bear so some fans believe
that torment and mage may have had a
secret romance torment might have taken
boats to Bear Island for booty calls in
the show though mage is now dead as our
elder daughters apparently because the
head of house Mormont is now 10 year old
Liana and she's awesome this tiny little
kid talking old began's stone at first
she's reluctant to support the Starks
because as she points out Sansa and
Jon's allegiance is questionable Jon's
technically a snow not a stark at least
until we get news of his true parentage
and Sansa has been married to a
Lannister and of Bolton in the end what
convinces Liana is doubles as argument
that they need to unite against the
White Walkers which is a little puzzling
what is Liana know of White Walkers
regardless she gives Jon and Sansa the
support of her soldiers all 62 of them
but just remember that if Liana meets
tormund in the future she may
unknowingly be meeting her father back
at Riverrun Jamie goes and chats with
the blackfish and this goes down a lot
like a dozen the books Jamie tries to
get him to surrender blackfish holds a
bunch of smack so it looks like Jamie's
going to have to attack Riverrun and
break his oath to Catelyn however things
might change when Brianna arrives maybe
some peaceful resolution might be
possible the stocks go to speak to Lord
Glover a Deepwood Motte and he flat out
refuses to support them he doesn't want
to fight alongside wildlings he doesn't
want to anger the Bolton's and he feels
he was failed by the Starks under Robb
remember Rob's marriage to talas has
screwed up the alliance with the Freys
which led to the red wedding which led
to the defeat of the north so Robb Stark
thinking with his dick kind of screwed
over the Glovers Glover talks about the
suffering of his family during the war
and were reminded that all these
struggles between Starks and Lannister's
and Tully's and Bolton's don't just
affect the lords and ladies at the top
they affect the people who serve them
and those people do have a right to be
mad when their failed by their overlords
Yara and Theon take a pit stop in
volantis while Yara and a Ironborn party
it up
Theon suffers this episode is called the
broken man but it could be called the
broken men because look how many there
are
Theon Edmure Sandor and Gregor who have
arguably Jamie John and Davos one of the
great things about Game of Thrones is
that it shows that war has consequences
that people get hurt in ways that don't
always get better
anyway Yara tells Theon to man up or die
which
is the Ironborn approach to therapy and
Yara outlines her plan to sail to marine
and LA with an heiress so that she can
take back the Iron Islands the question
of course is whether Euron can get there
first
back in the north Devils and the Starks
discussed their situation they've got
two thousand wildlings two hundred horn
143 Masons forty two more months and one
one one which isn't enough to beat some
5000 Bolton's plus however many numbers
and car stocks they've got so Sansa
writes a letter to Littlefinger asking
him to bring his Knights of the Vale
which will probably make all the
difference it's also possible that the
blackfish and the Tully's might arrive
to help and there are also the manderlys
one of the largest northern houses that
as far as we know still haven't taken a
side however it turns out this battle of
the bastards is going to be huge back at
the Riverlands three men come and
threaten raise village demanding horses
and food they seem to be from the
Brotherhood without banners that outlaw
group are you mates in season three the
Brotherhood is founded to protect the
common folk and they do do some dodgy
stuff like stealing supplies from people
on a promise to eventually pay them back
but these three guys are acting like
straight-up bandits and soon we see them
do much worse in Braavos Eyre books are
shipped to take her back to Westeros
then she goes for a walk and gets
attacked by the wife she escapes but
with a gut full of stab wounds if this
was any other character you think she's
gonna die right but this is Arya she's
been offered an orange storyline for
ages training for like two seasons
there's no way they're going to suddenly
kill her off now and make a whole arc
lead to nothing so how is she going to
survive
it looks like she needs help and right
now lady crane is the closest thing I
has got to a friend in this city so
maybe crane will find her somehow heal
her and send her on away to Westeros it
might be that simple but there are a lot
of crazy theories about more complicated
way as this could go down like some
people think that the wife is actually a
kind of a split personality of Arya like
Fight Club Tyler Durden type deal or
maybe that I you used some acting tricks
to fake her wounds with pig's blood or
something they're both cool ideas but
probably the most likely crazy theory is
the idea of the person who was stabbed
isn't Arya because remember we're
dealing with faceless assassins here
people who can magically take on the
appearance of other people so maybe the
person who was stabbed isn't Iyer but
jackin because we have seen jackin where
I use face before and we've seen jack
and die for aya before he drinks poison
so that I had dozens in season five the
reason Jack and still around is that
he's not really a person he's no one
he's just a face that can be worn by any
faceless man it is confusing but the
point is that we know that Jack and can
look like aya and that Jack ins willing
to die for her so maybe he's doing it
again
dying in is placed so that the real aya
can escape this would explain a lot
because the eye of this episode acts
really different to the ayah of last
episode last episode she hides out with
a sword drawn and looks like she knows
she's being hunted by assassins and
she's taking it seriously
but this episode I of wanders about in
the open not paying attention to her
surroundings she seems to have found the
time for a haircut and a new outfit and
she doesn't even have a sword at her
belt she walks different she talks
different she uses a right hand when I
err is left-handed everything about her
is off so maybe she's not aya but Jack
and pretending to be Ida and the really
difficult question is why would Jack and
do this why would he die in Aya's place
maybe what's going on here is that this
is all an elaborate test of the wife
because she's been a pretty rubbish
faceless man lately she's meant to be no
one with no desires no personality just
pure obedience but she clearly enjoys
tormenting IO she clearly wants to kill
her Jack and tells her not to let eius
suffer and yet the wave stabs are you in
the gut so she dies slowly and painfully
the wife is failing a training so maybe
Jack an arranged all this to [ __ ] with
her somehow
it's hard to guess that the specifics
but maybe we'll just have to wait and
see either way it seems all but certain
that IO will somehow survive this back
in the Riverlands the Hound finds that
Rey and his people have been slaughtered
presumably by these guys from the
Brotherhood and this is a pretty crazy
thing we've never seen the Brotherhood
do anything this bad before and from the
looks of the food on the ground they
don't even do it for supplies so why the
fact that Rey is hand might be a hint
because in the books the Brotherhood
really starts to go downhill when their
original leader Barrack dies and is
replaced by a new leader called Lady
Stoneheart
we won't spoil who's to
heart is because she might still appear
in the show eventually but she is called
the hang woman for her habit of hanging
her enemies stone heart does lead the
Brotherhood down a dark violent path so
she might be the explanation for what
happened here but as far as we've seen
even she will only kill the guilty we've
never seen her Massacre whole villages
so basically we don't know why the
Brotherhood would do this what we do
know is that sandals coming for them he
takes his axe and goes after the
Brotherhood which probably won't end
well for them it's going to be awesome
to see how sandals involved in the story
ahead he might meet Brienne again
because they're both in the Riverlands
he might reunite with IO and she returns
to Westeros he might see Sansa again and
maybe sandal will meet his brother
Sandor and Gregor Clegane have the
angriest bloodiest sibling rivalry in
all of Game of Thrones Gregor was the
one who burned sandals face back in the
day and they both come a long way since
Sandor almost dies and rises as a
changed man and Gregor dies and is
resurrected as a silent giant and zombie
there is a theory that if Gregor
represents Cersei in a trial by combat
the faith will be represented by Sandor
so the brothers Clegane two of the
biggest most powerful warriors in
Westeros will fight before all King's
Landing in the biggest most spectacular
clash in the series this theory is
called cleganebowl
thank you for watching and thank you to
all patrons for supporting this channel
including Jason adyghe Muller Jason
pants Andy broth ken gray Adam alladhina
Jessica stone Weaver and turd Ferguson
Cheers
you